the SNL Legend tackling the subjects
that most comedians wouldn't dare go
near
being a liberal
[Music]
you see them alone
in their cars with their masks on
I never did that but uh Rob's special
wake up in America I woke up I'm so
sorry is streaming right now on Fox
Nation and Rob joins us to talk about it
welcome thank you so nice to be here
during the sinking of the submarine near
the Titanic you know you just don't want
to be involved in anything or if it goes
bad and you're like what was he thinking
you know I don't do paraglia I don't do
any of that but I saw an Uber do that
you just hold my hand and I'm gonna I
saw I was an Uber on the way here and
I'm not taking that
long it's interesting I don't want it I
didn't look good you know what I mean
you think the streets are safer you
think the streets are safer yeah I don't
know maybe I'm wrong but anyway it's
hard to follow that I saw that you know
on the way out here that they can put me
on after the submarine sinking yeah
thank you appreciate it Gutfeld made a
lot of Submarine jokes in the commercial
brick that is not some Sun Ray material
you got to listen to it not true I just
said there was a missing sub was Brian
stelter around
tell us about your special well it was
just uh you know something the last
three years I just could not work you
know I went to every place that was
still open and sometimes you'd have to
be like you'd have to you know the
audience would have to sit like you know
five feet away from each other and I
said I'll go there and I just wanted to
work and then so this is the culmination
of the last couple years of uh of all
the stuff that I've been working on and
it was very nice that the you know I'm
very appreciative of Fox Nation to go
they'll put it on there unedited and
just you know you know it's important to
have free speech and kind of I to bring
people to a sense of calm in a way
subvert them through comedy yeah this is
a pretty good thing and I think it's
like it's just for laughs you know you
can you can I bring up things like you
know people don't know what a woman is
you know and then you get to a joke I'm
not talking about any issues it's using
those issues to get to something funny
everybody knows what a woman is a woman
is you know someone who wakes up at two
o'clock in the morning to kill a spider
in the bath
I've done that yeah my wife did that you
know and then I get one then you go and
she said you didn't cannot I said well
you didn't tell me how big it was
I need to come back tomorrow when I have
pants and a weapon but it's a lot of fun
and it is interesting because you know
you learn from The Comedians even the
comedians very liberal comedian like
Sarah you know
um Sarah Silverman and she just gets to
just they talk about horrible things
through an interesting gets the audience
to not even realize they're approving of
her getting to it so you learn from that
and then there's some great comedians
out there and I think a lot of them are
are trying to subvert some some thinking
that maybe needs to be rethought that's
all do you find it frustrating that like
there's so few out there that are
actually taking risks but there's there
there are other ones that are there I
would say that they could be taking more
risks yeah but you see the great ones
and there are you know there's always
been great communities but I never think
so many great all at their Peak at the
same time you know you got Bill Burr and
Dave Chappelle and Chris Rock Sebastian
maniscalco's hilarious and they are all
touching on it I mean they're are being
careful about it maybe more careful than
I am they're not on Fox Nation this
weekend but in but God bless them and
they are you know I think it is whether
it's the left or right whether it's too
far to go and you have to bring back to
a place of reason and I think that most
people are reasonable you take like the
extremes on both sides most people don't
fit in that category so that this is a
funny show I don't think we get through
all of this woke culture stuff without
humor I think we have to have it in
order to take the sting out of it I hope
so well that was it you know if you if
you really look at it calmly not just
the 22nd or a tweet you know you can
really uh kind of subvert the the anger
because people can make sense you know I
don't know when math became right wing
you know yeah two plus two equals four
could be racist how did that happen can
we talk about that for a few seconds
what is the future of Comedy is it going
to go worse in terms of the
cancellations or well I I think that
there's going to be a good comedies good
comedy it's like there's bad football
you don't want to watch you know like
flag football around the corner you
don't want to watch it like pac-10
[Laughter]
or something not all the time at all
pac-10 was a pack 13 Now isn't it by the
way but I do think that the NFL people
are always going to want to watch it so
the great comedians people to watch like
Chris Rock's last comedy special is had
some brilliant stuff to it yeah and so
you're going to want to see that stuff
and you know so those are the guys I'm
trying to reach and and uh and hit and
and for better or worse I mean you see
how it goes it's for laughs and get
people to laugh and have a good time but
nothing should be off limits to it every
you should be able to laugh about
everything just how clever you get there
and get the audience to kind of not
realize they're okay with where you're
about to go I always love it when
comedians tell jokes about white people
because I can laugh about myself do you
find that liberals can laugh about
themselves I would say that they're more
defensive I would say like and I don't
know why they they are just you just
it's like an unfair ball game it's like
you know the Liberals you got like NBC
MSNBC CBS ABC but you got a Google
search engine you have everything what a
conservatives have we have one News
Channel and a guy that sells pillows can
we have that no let's you know
we also have Scott Baio and Kevin Sorbo
stop it
thank you so much for joining us
everyone check out us common many
special available now on Fox Nation hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else